all right thank you for coming
um yeah so I'm Teemo and I'm really
really excited to uh talk to you about
building a high log machine learning
powered service
um so what does this camera mean it's
kind of thinking you have this amazing
great AI model and now you want a
prediction I say you actually want
customers to use your API which is based
on machine learning
um to get a bit more context
um the experience to kind of do is I got
that entropy an entropy is a startup
that does transaction enrichment what
does it mean
foreign
so what it means is uh we get a lot of
like raw transactions uh like Bank
transactions and we have again
intelligence element we get structured
data out of this so in this transaction
for example on the left side is the
input and the right side is what we give
back to our customers so it's like the
merchant the logo the website the the
type of transactions in this case like
uh
a restaurant and that type of data we
give to fintechs and neobanks
um and we make it super easy for
developers to use this uh like two lines
of code and they can get this kind of
structured data out of venture sections
and people use it for all kind of use
cases
why is this a very hard problem is
because financial data is a mess there
are hundreds of different formats that
um Banks return kind of their
transaction data in and we've seen
literally everything a very long-term
sections very short transaction a lot of
like abbreviation shortcuts so in the
end when you really dig into this data
it is not easy to do and even for humans
it's it's quite challenging
um so kind of the only way we can do
this is using a lot of very smart
machine learning models to kind of have
the same level as intelligence as as we
humans have uh here again some samples
where uh you can see where it's hard we
got ambiguities so sometimes we see in a
central section is Seiki Seiki we don't
know if it refers to Circle K Calvin
Klein we need to get it out of context
um there are abbreviations of British AI
which is actually British Airways so a
lot of these very kind of edge case type
scenarios which are actually not edge
cases because it happens all the time
and why do we care about scalability
because we get a lot of data um I kind
of give you the exact numbers but it is
a lot of transactions that go through
our models and we need very high very
low latency so or b95 latency has to be
under 200 milliseconds in our SLA we got
millions of Samsung or training data set
we're at the moment we support six
languages French
German English Spanish and I think I
forgot to and we're a team Now 60
Engineers so we have a lot of Engineers
trying to they're all building new
models and we find need to find a way
that kind of scales well when you're
engineering team across so yeah
this is going to brief overview of how
entropy works
we've got the incoming transaction then
we have our first ml model which is uh
named entity recognition model so we
recognize every entity in a sentence
then we got some logic to kind of
actually find the actual entities
because if you just find Hulu we
actually need to know what is Hulu what
types of instruction and then we have
the latest states which kind of assigns
categories or recurrence for example if
you have multiple transactions we need
to find that every month you're paying x
amount to a Hulu for your subscriptions
so there are a lot of like different
models in this whole pipeline
um but yeah so this talk is going to be
about scaling up so scaling from this
one
amazing model that you have to actually
something that customers can use and
I'll kind of share you some tips and
tricks that we found on the way
um to that we use to to scale our ml
Services up
so first of all I'll start with scaling
the development cycle
um because what happens is
um you have the start of your own new
startup with this amazing AI idea and
you're gonna get more models and more
Engineers to work on your uh on your
startup and
what you want to do is you want to kind
of release new product product updates
as soon as possible as you can so what
we do at entropy is we got a couple of
uh things that we do that make it much
easier to deploy new change to your
model so have multiple people working on
the same ml pipeline without kind of
breaking stuff
how do we do that
um
we tried to modelize our models
by using clear interfaces we try to
automate as much as possible and I'll
kind of show you how how we did it more
in detail
so again this is kind of for uh our
Pipeline on right side
um what's very important you have your
big pipeline so it's not just one
machine learning model but like a lot of
kind of Ensemble models that work
together is to really have very clear
um modularization and what enables you
to do this is it enables you to have
separate teams that really own a
particular component and they can have
its own test sets they can have its own
dependencies so it's really its own kind
of microservice but then within kind of
an ml setting and
uh in this case you can kind of easily
have one team working on a particular
part without breaking down another part
and you can only do this if you make
very clear interfaces so for example for
named entity recognition model is a very
simple example but you
um before you even kind of start
splitting up in modules you have a big
meeting where you actually really sit
down it's like okay guys what is the
actual interface that we use and an
interface is simply like okay with this
input I want to get this output
um
and then what enables you to do is
because then after we can easily switch
anything inside so we our data
scientists can easily change the
underlying model they can easily use
something else
without breaking anything because the
interface is still the same so they can
change anything they want which enables
them to kind of quickly change to see if
they can improve the models without
breaking anything in production
because we really focus on kind of for
machine learning engineers and data
design just to focus on their particular
kind of world their domain and not care
about anything that's going on in
production and by kind of making clear
interface they can can easily do that
um yeah it kind of goes without saying
but it's very essential to have a a very
automated CI CD pipeline we we use
GitHub actions we're a big fan of it and
our kind of pipeline goes like this
anytime we have a new feature that could
be a change to a model it could be a new
model it could be kind of any change
that we have we automatically create new
PR some GitHub
and then we run our tests
um
and once these tests kind of run
um we automatically kind of get notified
of this whether it passes doesn't pass
and then we can automatically deploy it
to a staging environment and also to a
production environment
um the testing we do in kind of three
different ways so for machine learning
models uh we have three different types
of test sets which are all I think
essential in in what we do and the kind
of the general thing that we do is once
we release a new
model is we just test it on a very
representative test set so this is a
data set that is very like the real
world data that you will see in
production
the thing with machine learning is there
are a lot of stochastic models so
sometimes your Tesco could improve could
go down but that's fine as long as
you're a certain threshold with a new
model that it doesn't go too far under
above it it's fine but at the same time
you have sometimes very easy use cases
so for for us it would be a transaction
with the name Amazon we don't want to
fail on the transaction with a very kind
of common Merchants so we have a test
set with things that we should never
fail it's a very hard hard use case and
at the same time what we do is we do
some adversarial testing so you see in
the bottom here these are almost all the
central sections except maybe some idea
of the identification memories different
and what we do not want is that the
outputs in this case the category of the
transaction will change with the very
tiny chains in this number so in this
case we want all the three bottom
transactions to be predicted as
restaurant categories instead of the
food truck what you see on the bottom
and with these three tests we can be
really really sure that once we deploy
something new it will always be better
than what we have before and if it's not
better we just don't deploy it
um then again it's very important to
have test sets per component so per
component of this whole machine learning
pipeline but also still have these
integration tests because what could
happen is maybe the name entity
recognition model improves just based on
the test sets for the name that's
recognition models but then somewhere
down the line the other models which
uses
the output of the names iteration model
might actually fail again so on every
single change we still test every single
thing as a whole uh whole pipeline
um we have a kind of pretty neat way of
doing this because anytime I am changing
something I get notified on slack I
directly see my F1 score my changes and
I can directly see like if whatever
change I made is actually uh good enough
or not and a very nice little thing that
we do is we got regressions that we
automatically put in a Google sheet so
anytime our prediction stays on a test
set we directly see the differences in
these predictions and we can directly
see that in the Google Sheets
automatically kind of debug hey why is
this different what's going on and it
really helps us kind of move much faster
and deploy many more changes every day
uh yeah so then when you have this big
machine learning service that a lot of
customers use you cannot really have any
downtime so uh it's a very simple thing
but maybe some people don't think about
it
is how can you get zero downtown
deployment and a very like easy way to
do that is using blue green deployment
which intuitively just means whenever
you have a new change you spin up an
identical kind of services which are
exactly the same as what's running
production and once all of that is spin
up then you just switch the low balance
in front of it to kind of go to this new
a new environment and then it kind of
all works it's a very kind of intuitive
thing but very powerful to make sure
that you have zero downtown deployment
times
all right so this is the that was the
scaling part of the development now we
actually go through production
throughput so your amazing AI startup
now gets a lot of traction you get
hundreds of millions of transactions to
your API call and and you really need to
make sure that
um
that you can handle this this new load
so how do you do this
and this is gonna go overview
um but the first thing you do is you
start finding your bottlenecks because
it's very essential especially when you
have a more complicated pipeline to kind
of find out where in this pipeline
exactly is the slow part that you need
to optimize
um because for us it's very important to
have very low latencies what we do is we
measure every single component of our
Pipeline and this is just an example of
how we do it in grafana so for every
kind of single component we measure what
is for example the uh the processing
time of that component and once you do
that you have easy insight into which
part you need to focus on because there
is no point in trying to optimize code
which might only be one percent of your
processing time you want to focus on the
biggest weakest kind of parts
so yeah once you find it there uh are a
couple of things
um let's say you have a model which is
very very slow because it's a big model
um and you want to optimize a very
well-known thing in a machine learning
world is model distillation and it's
kind of intuitive thing where you have
this big model that you trained
um but it might not be using its full
kind of knowledge capacity so what you
can do is you can have a smaller
component which kind of just takes uh
the same knowledge but have a much
smaller component that can run much
faster and doesn't use hmos memory um
you can do and we actually do this a lot
in our
in our models another thing that you can
do is
is kind of split multiple models up in
kind of like a sharing model so for
example we have at least three models
here that we run in our production
Pipeline and before there used to be
three different models so there used to
be three separate models that just run
by themselves
so the disadvantage of this is that
um you have to first of all keep these
three different models all of them in
memory so it takes up quite a bit of GPU
space
second thing is it takes time because
you need to ruin every the whole model
every single time so one thing you can
do is you can just let them share kind
of their base layers so what we did is
we we split these models up in in two
parts so the main part is kind of the
base model so that's kind of the main
main model that they use and then they
use the hidden state of this output and
we have a very tiny hat on top of that
and this makes training much faster
because you can have transfer learning
because you can kind of use the
knowledge from all the different data
sets that we have and especially
inference time is much faster because we
only need to do the base model once and
then we have these very small models on
top of it which run very very fast
then a very important thing that we uh
that we did is we transferred everything
to use a Triton inference server so
Triton is a product from Nvidia
that helps come with predictionized ML
models what it does it allows you to
submit kind of your models to the Triton
server and they handle all the running
of models which could be multiple models
in the same time it could be ensembles
kind of what you see in our case where
there's multiple models working together
and they make sure that the utility of
your gpus is really really high and in
that way you can kind of have a much
much faster speeds and the nice thing
about Triton is it supports all kinds of
model Frameworks which could be bytours
it could be Onyx could be tensorflow it
could be all kind of different different
Frameworks
um for us it allowed us to just run
models on very high speed with with very
kind of simple cheap gpus
um another nice thing about Triton is
that it helps with scaling because this
is kind of an overview of how our system
works
we got the API calls on the flash back
end which then kind of uh
become a are in a job queue and then we
have multiple workers kind of executing
these different apis calls and then what
they do for every ml machine learning
part they call Triton and Triton
executes the models because Triton are
kind of the GPU service where where all
of the models live
what happens if we got a lot of load
like suddenly there's a spike in traffic
um try them automatically kind of scale
up because we have a low ballers in
front of it it will automatically spin
up maybe two three or four like extra
surface which can then run much more a
lot and Triton handles a lot of this
stuff already automatically for you
um as well as it is able to run multiple
models comparingly if you have multiple
batches it will automatically kind of
squash them together
and that's kind of what I see here
um we all probably know that during
training we all use batches so we don't
do a single data point and use that to
kind of train on it we always most of
the time kind of batch stuff together
because it's much faster because you
make sure you actually use most of your
GPU
but in a production environment you
don't really want to always batch stuff
you still want to have this kind of near
real-time experience where if you just
send one API call you want to kind of
directly let it run through your models
with Triton there's a very nice thing
which called Dynamic batching where you
can still achieve this effect and how it
works is it's some kind of like buffer
that let's say wait still there are at
least 64 items in that buffer or maybe
let's say 200 milliseconds elapses and
then it will execute all of these things
in the buffer in one particular go and
it's a very neat way to kind of make
sure you have a
more batching features without really
having the downside of waiting too long
for patches also Triton helps with
queuing so again if there's a certain
big spike of API calls it will keep them
in a queue and kind of when there is
more capacity again I will execute them
and this is all all given for you so we
are really really happy with with this
Triton server
last thing that's really nice it gives
you all these metrics so the slides I
just showed you before Triton has a lot
of automatically integrated metric that
can be sent to grafana to analyze for
example whether you're using your GPU
very well or just the time that it needs
to execute so it's very very helpful to
see how much capacity we need on our
servers whether we are kind of
making sure that we we run everything in
time
all right then a totally different way
to sometimes optimize some of your
computational time is using feature Flex
because what we've seen with
um
with our customers that they don't
always need everything we do we have a
full product but there are certain
things that certain customers are not
interested at all so what we can do with
feature flag is just enable or disable
certain features because it's kind of a
waste if you run your full machine
learning pipeline while customers are
not even using any of this and feature
facts enables you to Simply switch on or
switch off certain parts of this this
pipeline
only thing which is uh not that that
nice about it is that testing becomes
much harder because if you have 20
different feature Flags if you really
want to test your system well you need
to kind of test all the different
combinations of these features like so
it's a bit of a trade-off but for us it
allowed us to save quite a bit of
computational power for for quite some
use cases
um yeah there's another thing that kind
of goes without saying
um but anything in your your pipeline
that you can do in parallel so that's
not dependent on each other just do it
in parallel
um for us async IO is is uh perfect it's
super easy to use
um
and allows you to quickly run multiple
asynchronous operations in parallel so
here it's just very quick snippet that
allows you to make like 100 API equals
or database queries or simultaneously
without kind of doing them sequentially
all right then another thing which is
very common in uh in in like I know the
background world as we all know about
caching people cache websites people
cache database queries but actually you
can use it very very well for machine
learning models as well because what
we've seen is that a lot of customers
send us exactly the same data for
example transactions could be exactly
the same and if it's a model or like
other types of computations which take
quite some time to to process it's a bit
of a waste to do that if you already
just calculated the same exact value for
the same input so we make use of caching
quite a bit
both what kind of model inference and
also for kind of external queries
really relining on Reddit
um which is very easy to use and and
really nice if you are a small scale but
we got into quite some issues some very
interesting weird issues that we spent
hours and hours on trying to figure out
and we also reached kind of the maximum
limit of of memory because Reddit stores
everything uh fully in memory and we
literally reached kind of the maximum
servers at AWS so we needed to find a
different way to to still have caching
then we moved everything to Sila DP
um
celery is actually a normal database
but we can kind of simulate this key
Value Store type of thing from redis
quite easily and we've seen that it
massively improved
um at least the cost because again it
doesn't keep everything in memory it can
keep some things on disk and even our
rides and reads were virtual faster
because celadv used a very smart
combination of still putting some stuff
in memory and putting some stuff on disk
so yeah for us it's been a real real
life saver and especially because we are
getting more data more data in our
caches it it seemed to scale pretty
pretty well for us
yeah then another little thing about
this caching is
normally with caching you have one
particular input
and you have that stored in your cache
but sometimes even if the input is very
similar you can still use
um
still use kind of the cache that you
already calculated for example here with
Amazon Market let's say that Amazon
Market we have some information that we
need to look for Amazon Market is not in
our cache but we do have information for
Amazon Marketplace so what we do if it's
not in our cash we still look for very
small similar cash items because
especially when we're short on time we
need to give kind of the best best
alternative and and this is kind of a
combination that seems to to work quite
well
um and again also for normal cash let's
say we have this this query to look up
information about Amazon market so we
need to find information about this
company
and we need to wait on some external
source to to load this sometimes that
can take maybe 100 milliseconds
sometimes it can take a second but we
need to make sure that any single time
we we give back our results very fast so
we cannot always wait for the external
external data sources
um one thing we do is is just time out
external API skills but then it's a
waste because then you call this
external data source but you're actually
just canceling the request so we don't
really cancel the request we still store
it in cash so that we have it the next
time these are very like little tricks
that we do to kind of optimize our cache
another nice thing that we do with
caching is this uh smart looking
Behavior so what can happen is we got
one big batch of transactions so let's
say we get a thousand transactions at
the same time that we need to process
and maybe just a random example 50 of
them all contain transactions about AWS
so instead of
can getting information about AWS in our
external sources 500 single times that
we all do in parallel it's a bit of a
waste again because it's all the same
thing so a neat little thing that we do
is uh is we kind of have locks so
anytime that one particular part of our
system requests something in our cash or
in our external data source from AWS we
first make sure that nobody else is
already making this request nobody else
in the system is is doing that and then
we do that by just having a simple lock
in our cache like hey I'm actually
requesting something about AWS don't
request it as well just wait for me to
finish and then I'll give you the result
and yeah that's what we do and we save a
lot of money but also time doing doing
this type of stuff because you're not
overloading your external sources with
all the same requests you're only doing
it once and using that for the other
results as well
all right then another thing that we uh
used to do a lot is uh move some of our
code to rust so in general we start
writing our models or algorithms or like
everything in our system mostly in
Python because python is very fast for
developers because that's why we're here
we love python is a very intuitive easy
language to write stuff and to build
stuff but as we all know it's hella slow
especially if you don't use certain
libraries which factorize operations or
just have kind of the actual code in C
or in Rust it's quite slow
um so again once we measured a lot of
parts of our system we found out a
certain part of the system were quite
slow and we just saw could we optimize
this and the answer was yes we could
optimize it by literally transferring
that particular component to rust and
rust is really nice it's not as hard to
learn as C but it does kind of have the
speed of C and C plus plus
um so we we've been using it quite a bit
and the nice thing is they're
um but you can easily make bindings for
python so you can literally call the
same function that you used to call in a
normal python code but now it executes
in the actual riska and first this kind
of combination allowed us to still move
fast to develop a lot of stuff very fast
but at the same time when it's really
necessary to optimize speed we can
optimize it by transferring some code to
to rust and we haven't only been doing
it for our own libraries there's been a
lot of libraries in the python ecosystem
that be doing this well number one is
tokenizes first was written in Python
and again I've got a moves to rust
solos is a really nice alternative if
you want literally have the pandas
interface but much faster inference
space
and by that thing a well-known data
validation Library I already kind of
literally do this and we we just follow
them here's a simple sample we have a
model which is called the segmenter
there's literally segments words into
multiple words so in this case the input
would be the New York Times that would
be the space new space York Times
um and this is a very simple Benchmark
where the native python codes would take
a
uh we take like six times uh it's what
we six times slower than the actual risk
and it's a weird thing that we've seen
in practice that anytime when we write a
naive implementation in Rust it would be
six to seven times faster than the
original uh python code so that's a
quite some sweet optimization
all right
so yeah now we are uh kind of in the
last part of this this talk
we've seen that you got a lot of new
load a lot of API requests to your
machine learning Services which also
means you got a lot of new data and you
got to support a lot of new data
patterns as well because if you get so
much new load maybe you haven't trained
on all that that data but at the same
time you cannot label uh millions
millions of data points like that's
impossible so what do you do
um for us
what we do is we heavily use our
large-scale sentence clustering because
again for us it's all based on textual
information like the transaction
description
and
yeah so here's an example and these are
just a couple of transactions which are
kind of all the same but at the same
time they're all different because they
look slightly different
and this is another example for example
if you see the left side it's just a
bunch of sentences in a random order
it would be pretty hard or like it's
already harder to kind of see a pattern
in here well on the right side we use
sentence clustering to kind of group
semantically similar sentences together
and this enable issue to do a couple of
things
for example we can label data faster if
you see this again it's much easier to
assign categories to the sentences on
the right side compared to the left side
because here you can easily see okay
it's about puzzle stem so probably the
label would be the postal stamp if you
have some integration problem
um because now you have this nice little
order you can actually uh yeah like I
said label much faster but you don't
always need to label everything as well
maybe it's already good enough for a
model if you only have one or two
particular sentences per group
so what you can do then is you just
select kind of the most representative
sentence per group and only let your
label is labeled that particular
sentence because it's kind of a waste if
you keep on labeling almost all the same
input data especially for models it's
really interesting to show an as much
diverse range of data samples because
then your model gets smarter and smarter
if there's a kid in school and you give
him the same same like exercise like
okay calculate two plus two calculate
two plus two two plus two like he won't
really learn much but if you give it a
very kind of diverse range of exercise
they will learn much more and the same
applies for machine learning
um so yeah it reduces the number of
labels that you need it's easy to uh to
debug mistakes as well
because you can also run the same
samples through your models and see what
it outputs and if you see that in a
certain cluster it outputs all kind of
different different outputs you already
know like hey maybe it's missing some
training data here because maybe it's
not as as good here so it's much easier
to have an overview of of your of your
things
see
yeah and then it helps in finding noise
what we've seen is we have a lot of
training data where our labelers again
are also human and also make mistakes so
in machine learning it's very important
to have good quality labeled data and in
practice you've seen that isn't always
the case so again what we've done a lot
of the work in is just literally going
through our label training data sets and
making sure that everything is correct
and again seeing that in a nice order
helps a lot with kind of seeing
structural mistakes that labelers make
do this we could not use kind of the
more well-known kind of clustering
libraries so DP scan and K means were
not applicable because DB scan squares
quadratically and again we're dealing
with a lot of data here so our training
data is sometimes in the millions of
samples so it just doesn't scale well
and couldn't be run on a single machine
k-means wasn't applicable because we
don't know the number of clusters like
there could be many different uh
different transaction types different
tracks and patterns that we do not know
beforehand
so what we did is we come up with a kind
of in in kind of
merge uh like a I don't know how to
explain a
a method to batch up a lot of the things
and immerse things together so instead
of clustering everything at once and
comparing every single data point with
every other data point we make chunks
and in these chunks we do the clustering
and we try to find clusters and then if
we find these clusters we merge them
together and make them in bigger
clusters and there's a whole iterative
approach which I don't think I have the
time for now to go into more detail but
it's a very nice little intuitive thing
that you can use to literally cluster
tens of millions of sentences and
transactions
uh if you want to learn more literally
just Google sense clustering and we pop
up as the first result or uh click this
link once you find the find the slides I
go to into much more detail how we did
this and you can read more there
um yeah so I think this is the last
slide
what you can do as well in your uh data
pipeline is again automate a lot of
these daily jobs so what we've been
doing is we use flights which is really
nice tool for developers to create these
uh these data pipelines that have to run
every day or have to run every five
minutes
and one single thing that we do is for
example this pipeline so anytime our
labelers send us new uh training data we
automatically
retrain our models let's say every day
and then we can automatically deploy the
models once over the test passes and
then again when we find new mistakes
because again the new model is live and
maybe it's not good in certain areas we
automatically send those mistakes or
parts where the model is not sure
because we have confidence scores and we
can use those to see hey in in these
type of transactions we we're not really
sure what to predict so we can send
especially those transactions again back
to our labelers to have human labelers
annotate those and again use it in model
retraining so it's this whole kind of
nice Loop that can run every single day
and in that way you can make very
scalable machine learning pipelines that
get better and better every single day
and then fully automated with with
little humor intervention
so yeah kind of the summary
um when you want to scale on a mouse
surface uh again start just making these
very imperfect
uh both prototypes because in the end
you just want to have something that
works
and then step by step try to optimize it
try to use some of the tips and tricks
that I showed you to see how you can
make it faster uh and how make it more
scalable as well so it's always like a
challenge in between pure software
engineering and pure ML and there is no
Silver Bullet but you you just have to
try it out and see what what works for
your use case but I really hope that
some of these trips and tricks were
helpful for you and yeah let me know if
you have any questions and we're also
hiring so uh yeah if you're interested
let me know after the talk and we can
yes go ahead so if you get a brand new
financial transaction right yeah how do
you know that your nem is actually
working that I've tried you know
classified the different entities
correctly like the example you said for
CK if that is a brand new soundtrack
right how do you know if it is Calvin
Klein or something else how do you know
that for a certainty it's right yeah so
I mean our models can
barely like it's not that we can get
better than human activities if we as a
human cannot tell probably a model can
tell either
um but I don't know if they share with
your question but you can feedback from
the users like if I see on my screen
that yeah exactly it's somewhere yeah so
we're not a banker cell so we don't like
we're not a consumer product so it's
mostly Banks or filter companies that
use over it and they and they their uses
uh see mistakes they can report it and
then we get it back and then again we
send this again to remember and there's
this whole kind of pipeline of
literature so we definitely have a
recording endpoint here one more
question yeah we use like pre-trained
models like bird or gbt or do you you
have your own in-house train models
um yeah so they're all Transformer based
models that we then happily
as you train models that are earlier in
the pipeline I assume that means you
also have to retrain everything that's
like after you know pipeline exactly how
do you manage that when you have like uh
long chains of models that take forever
to to vote for it to train while you
still have the particular data that's
coming in yeah
um so yeah like I said the deployment of
models can be built individually so we
can still deploy they have a model all
the way up high in the pipeline and
um and do that like isolated because a
lot of our tests we can directly see if
it impacts one of the models down the
line if there are some changes that's
like really big then we just retrain all
the models like there's no real real
money to them
how did that process work when you have
to retrain everything do you start it's
like
the appointment as well sorry
uh how does that when you do have to
retrain it yeah do you also do this sort
of green deployment where you have like
your
um load balancer yeah
okay
training on the other environment I see
you know that's a very good point um so
with the blue green diploma it's really
essential that you make sure that
everything in let's say the blue uh
blue environment is the new new
deployment and everything in the green
is a nearby because if you have
let's say there's one model that you
updated with stock to updated model in
the other environment so you need to
make sure that all of these things are
kind of isolated because else it might
break certain things so that's yeah
any other questions
yes so the the Trenton server that
you've mentioned am I saying it right is
it true today
so that sounds almost like AWS Auto
scaling and stuff like that right so why
did you guys go with Clinton first was
it was it like Greenhouse that you came
up with or was it like still third party
yeah no training is uh open source
project from Nvidia
um and you still can use the in
combination with your AWS Auto scaling
or kubernetes
AWS like wherever you get
um but try them
is a full gun of package that helps you
can do the mortgage because you can
automatically monitor for example GPU
usage where you can see hey if my
YouTube videos goes up and then I need
to order to it automatically handles
it's Auto like the load balance in the
front
one of the nice things about driving is
especially if you have multiple models
you can all have them on one particular
server together so you make sure that
again to be using
so it's not uh just that we choose it to
Auto scale stuff that we can do with AWS
because we still use the AWS our scale
and then
so a little bit more on Nvidia Triton
since I'm also not as familiar with it
when you say the following one server
like it's capable of everything in one
rock and it's at rock and roll
s
yeah uh to be honest I I I don't know
that there's the particular point
um
I do think we are working on
at least having
two isolated production environments we
do not have the same origin but I don't
really know a weird difference and then
you did mention it was a lot cheaper
yeah so
um do you have a metric like percentage
in terms of how much savings it was
yeah again I don't have the answer
um because again this talk is about
um
but I can definitely ask uh
what I do know
you have to kind of see this if you have
a separate server with a separate gpus
and you use only for one model then
another server for another model then
another server for another model right
now you kind of Squish them together and
you can make sure that they all run and
utilize the same view does it even
through how I understand it exactly cool
saving I would know I can add example
yeah
you think about like continuous training
studies right how do you I guess trade
off some of the like you have some more
data do you only update just in that
small batch it's like cheaper and
quicker to do or if you want to do
retrain on all of your data at that
point yeah uh so I imagine like you
don't want to lose information that
you've got in the past but sometimes if
you just use all of that to them
getting that model out and then
yeah no this is a very good point um I
know at least for certain models we
we've done a combination of this so we
once in a while maybe once every week or
once every month to train kind of every
training edit
Ed and we we fully train our baseballs
but then maybe if we have daily
deployments where we need to make a
quick fixes or we just have like a
little bit of new data we can easily
just fine tune a little bit so we still
reuse some of the base model and then
just fine tune on new or newer data
points to have exact kind of ways of
doing it it's a little yeah
but yeah this definitely will be yeah
um what's the magic behind caching
because you mentioned that uh if there
was something similar coming in then it
wouldn't it would almost do what I took
away from it it functioned almost like
under the hood there was some sort of
deduplication process is that a separate
model or does that all have handled
inside
um solo DB yeah not as just a kind of
like a utility function that we we use
um to General with cash it's like you
pull the catch first see if there's
nothing there even though being still
cool either the model or like an
external data source
in this particular thing there we
implement this smart working base for
the duplicate
application another easy way is to just
literally if you have to batch of a
thousand items of which 200 are
duplicates they're gonna already
duplicate them and then do the external
holes first this locking mechanism was a
very easy way that we could easily add
all the way to recycling without too
much
cool
all right if you guys any questions
we're outside of the booth um please
come by and we're happy to talk more to
you guys answer any questions so thank
you very much
[Applause]